يدخلوا كارثه الزلزال في تركيا اسبوعها
الثاني ونتحدث عن عشرات الالاف من القتلى
ومن المصابين ونتحدث عن اخرين ما زالوا
يحاولون انقاذهم من تحت الانقاض رغم تضاؤل
فرص النجاح هذه الانقاض لفظت كل الحياه من
داخلها لاصحابها
ولفظت ايضا ذكرياتهم التي حرصوا على
تسجيلها نشاهد الان من بين هذه الانقاذ
عشرات وربما مئات الصور على الاقل في هذا
المكان لسكان هذا المجمع السكني ولا نريد
اظهار اشكالهم في صور احتراما لخصوصيتهم
هذا هو الوضع التي الذي يمكن ان نشاهده
بين المباني المدمره في كهرمان مرعش الحال
مؤلم جدا والوضع سيء جدا كما نشاهد كتب
لطلاب وتلاميذ
واطفال كانوا ربما يستعدون لدرس اخر في
يوم اخر لكن كل ذلك بات اثرا بعد عين كما
نشاهد
غساله العربيه كهرمان مرعش